buen día soy el teniente coronel jorge
wilson serna lópez vicerrector de
educación continua distancia de la
policía nacional de colombia desde que
tengo uso de razón recuerdo como desde
niño siempre soñaba y era creativo no
solamente con los juegos sino con los
juguetes y ahora después de 23 años de
servicio en nuestra amada institución
siempre he venido soñando y
desarrollando ideas
y es así como tanto con compañeros con
subalternos y hasta con los mismos
superiores ese tenido inconveniente
porque salimos de ese lugar de confort
es el lugar de confort que en algunas
ocasiones nos ha llevado a que cuando me
reconozcan y a veces el jorge serna
tiene muchas iniciativas pero pocas
acaba tibás y que realmente cuando
escuché eso yo di la razón a algunos
superiores compañeros dice- alternos que
decían eso
y encontré porque porque a veces esa
creatividad que nos queda en la mente
solamente la dejamos en pensamientos
tenemos muchas ideas ya veces no las
realizamos porque esas ideas
nos da el nos da temor de dar el
siguiente paso de realizarlas y ahí es
donde encontramos pasión y método no
solamente es colocar corazón y querer
hacer las cosas sino que necesitamos de
ese siguiente paso para generar un
método un desarrollo a esa idea
innovadora y así sean pequeñas así sean
grandes pero hay que empezar a
desarrollar y a soñar con ellas y ahí
vamos a encontrar y los invito y creo
que a todos nosotros nos ha pasado en
algún momento encontrando varios
obstáculos y yo encontré otro obstáculo
que era encontrarme con que esa idea ya
cuando la iba a realizar
se basaba en la perseverancia o en la
terquedad porque cada vez que salía una
idea puede generado algún obstáculo
económico
de línea jerárquica de la parte
logística de la parte de autorizaciones
pero empecé con esa con ese dilema o
estoy perseverando dentro de un
ejercicio o estoy generando una
terquedad la tercera es un defecto pero
la perseverancia es una virtud
y creo que nos ha pasado y les voy a
contar en esta mañana la historia de un
desarrollo de una idea innovadora que
realizamos y se empezó a construir desde
el 2012 cuando una película invictus me
inspiró
y como nelson mandela a través del
deporte en sudáfrica y un pueblo que
estaba dividido por el racismo que la
par está ahí
y una frase que cayó y caló en mi
corazón fue la que inició todo este
viaje y este desarrollo de este sueño
esta frase nelson mandela la inmortalizó
donde dice que el deporte tiene el poder
de transformar el mundo tiene el poder
de inspirar y de unir a la gente como
ninguna otra cosa nos une ahora que
estamos ya finalizando el campeonato
mundial de fútbol en el caso de nosotros
colombia cuando jugaba quien nos
celebraba un gol y se abrazaba con
personas que estaba al lado que ni
siquiera conoce ese efecto ese efecto el
deporte genera acercarse y abrazarse
celebrar un gol llenar de pasión y este
ejercicio de pasión y método fue el
desarrollo de acercar los países que
históricamente no teníamos alianza a
través del deporte
los primeros juegos mundiales de policía
pero para llegar a este viaje los
primeros juegos mundiales de policía
quiero hablarles que en el 2012
hicimos un acercamiento con la ucip y
esta foto que inmortalizó la suscripción
de la policía nacional de colombia a
esta organización que tiene y acoge más
de 90 países del mundo especialmente los
países árabes
pues queda inmortalizado en la memoria
de mucha gente pero detrás de esa foto
hay historias
que realmente a manera personal nos han
venido generando después de algunos años
risas
yo nunca había salido del país fue la
primera vez que salí del país y viajé 36
horas para llegar a cuba ya firmar ese
convenio y ese convenio se firma
y se hace esa alianza dos años antes con
yo no en el caso personal no hablaba una
sola palabra inglés y a través de google
pues me pude comunicar y generar esa
alianza y es una barrera que a veces
encontramos en los sueños y en las
innovaciones nosotros tenemos más
barreras intelectuales que físicas y a
veces el lenguaje el idioma nos permite
o nos empieza a generar ese tipo de
barreras y en este caso rompimos
barreras del idioma con países que
hablan ni siquiera inglés y pudimos
comunicarnos y acercarnos y ese sueño
desde el 2012 pues se desarrolló y se
empezó a construir en una idea
quijotesca para alguno loca pero fueron
los primeros juegos mundiales de policía
realizados en el año 2015 aquí en
colombia en bogotá en la entraña en el
alma máter de la escuela general
santander 36 cuerpos de policía de esos
36 nueve cuerpos de policía
de los países árabes
inicialmente para para esta organización
y para los países árabes colombia era el
lado oscuro de la luna' y ahora hacemos
parte nervio y entrañas de esa
organización
ese sueño quijotesco que nació en ese
2012 se ha venido reflejando no
solamente en los primeros juegos
mundiales de policía que lo realizamos y
los ganamos sino en los segundos juegos
mundiales que fueron en abu dhabi
emiratos arabes
46 cuerpos de policía a nivel mundial
participaron más de 2500 policías
asistentes y participantes en esos
juegos en cinco modalidades deportivas
pero aparte de eso una idea que nace de
la policía nacional de colombia y que
aparte de eso nosotros los policías de
colombia
fuimos acompañamos y asesoramos esos
segundos juegos mundiales de policía
junto que para mí fue un honor estar en
la inauguración y
y se barajaban los ojos
viendo como esa idea seguía y continuaba
en unos países diferentes con una
cultura y un idioma diferente pero que
para el próximo año también tenemos ya
los terceros juegos mundiales de policía
van a ser en milán italia y los cuartos
están programados para rusia
aparte de esto estamos
formando parte del comité ejecutivo como
vicepresidente del señor general gonzalo
ricardo londoño portela y yo como
miembro del comité ejecutivo y de
marketing de esta organización
esa perseverancia y esa terquedad que
encontramos en ese primer lugar les digo
esa perseverancia a los sueños hay que
continuar hay que dar ese paso no
solamente que quede en una idea en
creatividad que es que solamente en el
pensamiento hay que dar el próximo paso
a que tenga pasión y método pasión para
hacer las cosas con el corazón pero no
solamente necesitamos esa pasión para
realizar las cosas necesitamos un método
para realizarla y para desarrollarla
como se realizó con estos juegos
mundiales de policía y como a la fecha
seguimos sosteniendo esa relación con
estos países la invitación es a soñar es
a romper esos esquemas es a creer en
nuestra institución nuestra empresa en
lo que nosotros hacemos nadie se alía
con un débil nadie se alía con un débil
y nuestra institución es una institución
fuerte que debemos de ser
evangelizadores de nuestra institución
de nuestra amada policía nacional
debemos desarrollar
y mostrar toda esa oferta institucional
que tenemos y venderlo también hacia los
países
no solamente que tenemos alianza sino
que tenemos que generar ese acercamiento
que se hizo en este caso a través del
deporte el deporte en este caso fue una
excusa para acercarnos con esos países
el deporte no era el fin era una excusa
como nelson mandela lo hizo en sudáfrica